PROFESSOR: So let's look at
a last example of applying
the well ordering principle,
this time to something that we
actually care about-- a theorem
that really does require some--
The theorem is the
following famous formula
for the sum of a geometric
sum-- for a geometric series
or a geometric sum.
So the numbers on the left,
the powers of r starting at 1,
which is r to the 0 followed
by r, which is r to the 1,
followed by r squared, up
through the nth powerful of r.
You add all those numbers
up and it turns out
that there's a nice,
simple, fixed formula that
doesn't have those
three dots in it that
tells you exactly what the value
of that sum is in the formula.
As you can read is r to the n
plus 1 minus 1 is the numerator
and r minus 1 is
the denominator.
And the claim is
that this identity
holds for all
non-negative integers n
and for all real numbers r
that aren't 1 because I don't
want the denominator to be 0.
So how are we going
to prove this?
Well, I'm going to
prove it by using
the well ordering
principle, and let's suppose
that this identity didn't hold
for some non-negative integer
n.
So we'll apply the
well ordering principle
and we'll let m be
the smallest number
n where this equality fails--
it becomes an inequality.
Now, what I know
about m immediately
is that this equality, if
you look at it, when n is 0
the left-hand side comes down.
It degenerates to
just r to the 0, or 1.
The right-hand side,
if you check it,
is r minus 1 over r
minus 1, which is also 1.
So equality holds
when n is 0, and that
means that the least m for
which equality doesn't hold
has to be positive.
So, what we know
about the least number
where this equality fails
is that it's positive.
And that means in particular
since it's the least one
[? word ?] fails, if you
go down one to m minus 1,
the equality holds.
So we can assume that the sum
of the first m powers of r,
starting at 0 and ending
at r to the m minus 1,
is equal to the formula where
you plug in m minus 1 for n
and you get that formula
on the right, which
I'm not going to read to you.
Well, we can simplify
it a little bit.
If you look at the exponent,
r to the m minus 1 plus 1
is after all just r to the m.
So repeating what I've
got is that the sum
of those first powers of r
up to m minus 1 we can assume
is equal to the formula r to the
m minus 1 divided by r minus 1
because m failed and this
was the number one less where
it had to succeed.
So now we take the
obvious strategy.
What I'm interested
in is properties
of the sum of the
powers up to r to the m.
Now, the left-hand
side is the powers
up to r to the m
minus 1, so there's
an obvious strategy for turning
the left-hand side into what
I'm interested in.
Namely, let's add r to
the m to both sides.
So the left-hand side
becomes just the sum
that I want and the
right-hand side becomes
this messy thing, r to the
m minus 1 over r minus 1
plus r to the m.
Well, let's just
simplify a little bit.
Let's put r to the m over
the denominator, r minus 1,
which I do by multiplying
it by r minus 1.
And then it comes
out to be r to the m
plus 1 minus r to
the m over r minus 1.
And I collect terms
and look what I got.
I've got the formula r
to the m plus 1 minus 1
over r minus 1, which means
that the identity that I was
originally claiming,
in fact, holds
at m contradicting the assertion
that it didn't hold at m.
In other words, we've
reached a contradiction
assuming there was a least
place were equality fails,
that means there's
no counter example
and the equality holds for
all non-negative integers n.
So here's the
general organization
of a well ordering proof
which we've been using.
Let's just summarize it
into a kind of template
for proving things.
So what you have in mind is that
there's some property, P of n,
of non-negative integers.
And what you'd like to
prove is that it holds
for every non-negative integer.
So for all n in non-negative
integers, P of n holds.
And we're going to
try to prove this
by the well ordering
principle, which
means that we're going to define
the set of numbers for which P
doesn't hold.
That is, the set of
counter examples,
and call that C. So C is the
set of non-negative integers
for which not P of n holds.
Now, by the well
ordering principle
there's got to be
a minimum element,
call it m, that's in C.
And at this point the job--
by assuming that m is the
smallest counter example,
we have to reach a
contradiction somehow.
Now, up to this second
bullet it's the template,
but the third bullet is where
the real math starts and there
isn't any template anymore.
How you reach a
contradiction is by reasoning
about properties of P of n,
and there's no simple recipe.
But the usual organization
of the contradiction
is one of two kinds.
You find a counter example
that's smaller than m--
you find a C that's in the
set of counter examples
and C is less than m that would
be a contradiction because m
is the smallest thing at C.
Or you reach a contradiction
by proving that P does
hold for m, which means
it's not a counter example.
And those are the
two standard ways
to organize a well
ordering proof.